anything I can do to help my immune system get back up as I finish up my
predisone for poison IV. Well so steroids, the problem with taking steroids
is that steroids reduce your blood cell count, right? So that's the long-term
use of steroids is higher risk of cancer. Now you're not on a long term, you're
running a couple weeks for the poison IV. I think it's gonna be fairly easy for
your immune system to bounce back. Plus I you never did tell me the exact dose
you were on, but you were probably on like 60 milligrams than 50 than 40
than 30 or something like that and dropped out. You're gonna bounce back
just fine. I wouldn't be horribly concerned about that. Where people really have
problems, acute use of steroids causing cancer is when they have a highly acute
flare and then they go on high dose steroids. I had a person, I think it was on
500 milligrams predisone. You're on 40 for five days, 20 for five days. Okay. This
person had an autoimmune issue and had a acute flare could get off the floor of
this garage, ER visit, ambulance taken with the ER, acute autoimmune flare of
rheumatoid arthritis or any other arthritis or something like that. What about
high dose steroids? I think it was on 1000 milligrams a day, 500 milligrams a day,
for just two days or then down from there, ended up with prostate cancer a month
later. I mean it was that fast. So that's that's the kind of dosage that you're
looking at. Otherwise a person that has like severe lumbar spine issues, disc issues
that are surgical or botched surgery and they're on long term 40 milligrams of predisone has
an increased risk of cancer because it just basically damages other parts of your body.
You know, everything's connected. So not only did it decrease, well it glutes
out cold, but it affects your immediate inflammatory reaction to cancer growth and immediate
inflammatory reaction, cytokine reaction to infection too. And then the person is more
susceptible to like H. Pylori, which can itself cause cancer. So you got the secondary causes
that go along with it. Also regarding predisone, just how horrible is this for cancer? Okay,
I explain that after not getting poisoned, I mean for several years, excuse me, I've had
now it now and and about eight months ago predisone, both times I get the rash blisters itchy horrible
for these three weeks. But if I need to forgo predisone for the sake of my cancer, I will try
without it next time. Yeah, I don't know if you can try to, I mean some people, like I said last
week are just more susceptible to poison ivy. We used to live in the woods years ago and poison ivy
everywhere. I got just absolutely immune to it. I could literally pick it with my bare hands out of my
darted, never got a rash from it after my initial first rashes and stuff. But not everybody's
like that. So yeah, you just got to really be careful about exposure to it.
Would you know, should you forgo using predisone for the sake of your cancer?
Yeah, that's smart. I know everybody on this call has cancer. They want to get better from the
cancer. But you have to treat your body holistically. You have to use wisdom. So sometimes you have to go
off your anti-cancer supplements to treat something else for a period of time. Sometimes you have to
use your knife to treat pneumonia for a period of time. So that's the idea of just using wisdom.
It would not be so single-minded and anxiety-ridden about one thing. We can be so obsessed with
curing cancer that we can be doing more damage to the rest of our body. And we can be doing damage
to our relationships. We can be obsessed with correcting one thing that affects the rest of our
life. I've often said, and I'll say it again, we have to be careful not to make curing cancer
an idol in our life either. God is very much against idolatry. So yes, we all want to be
curative cancer. We also want to feel great. I think from a Christian perspective, you learn as much
as you can. You do as much testing as you need to do. You figure out the things and then you follow
a plan of attack using as much wisdom as that you could possibly gain. And ultimately, you're leaving
the results to God. You have to do that. If you're going to be completely obsessed with whatever
is going on in your body, that in itself is going to cause enormous amount of anxiety. And what does
anxiety do? Shots down your adrenal glands, shuts down your immune system, shuts down your parasympathetic
system, shuts down your detoxification pathways, causes an increase in inflammation and will hinder
your healing from everything possible. So I can't emphasize how important it is to gain as much
wisdom as possible. And then just follow a plan and relax into that plan of trust God. So